does this feel good all of us together
again
like old times they're getting big
you're getting big
i i would have i would have called i
didn't know she was sick i would have
called
put me down for cheese is she is she
better now
i don't think this shooting was racially
motivated what an arm that guy's got an
arm
i don't see any evidence that it was
that's all that's all i'm saying
but it's good to be out i will ask the
pronouns i didn't real i didn't know
that
i saw something about that on uh their
their
instagram ketchup and mustard is fine
it's over the election's over i'm having
fun
you know meghan markle's a rotten [ __ ]
well you tell her to shut the [ __ ] up in
my day every single person got molested
every one of us my ancestors didn't do
anything to anybody honey i've been on
the internet for one year
and now i finally am out of my house
because my wife is dead of course
the vaccine is interesting and that's
what i'm gonna say
i think people are gonna spend their
stimulus money on crack
yeah i was molested she's indian she's
black she's asian what is she what is
kamal i'm happy i was invited here
and now you're saying i should leave my
belief about the world is that everyone
exists to [ __ ] me in my mouth
and if i don't cut off their dicks well
then i get [ __ ] in the mouth and if
your kids don't want to hear that
send them inside hey i'm white
get it you get it i want to thank you
i want to thank your wife and i want to
thank
the other one hey come here come here
you want to suck my [ __ ]